because we're men we're not allowed to
communicate
well that's that's the pressure that's
been put on you who's stopping
what are you talking about you know what
it is I think it is I think men and
women communicate differently 100 that's
what it is it's like women want men to
communicate with them the way they
communicate do you get what I'm saying
and so when you like when you when
you've been quiet for three hours or
whatever
and a woman comes to you and says
she wants you to communicate with her
the way she communicates yeah I don't I
me I don't necessarily communicate like
that so you're not first of all you're
not going to get me to communicate on
your terms you're not going to
manipulate situation and and secondly if
and when it's time for me to communicate
I can talk to you it's not a problem but
like I said if if you're communicating
to draw me back onto I've always said
this right women have a battlefield and
men have a battlefield in the way they
communicate
for me I always tell them I never get
drawn onto women's Battlefield when an
argument because they argue differently
from us and they will drag you onto that
Battlefield and they will win because
you are not well versed in the way in
which women argue I feel I feel like
women argue with manipulation they argue
with emotion and you know when all when
all else fails they'll pull the
victimhood card yeah do you know what
I'm saying and so it's like if I get
drawn into that they will always win I I
did a video on this I never really got
triggered argue with with with most most
women like obviously that I have some
female friends that are intelligent and
you know they think in a logical way and
so we can have these kind of discussions
but 99 of the time I don't because most
of the time that the me to engage in
discussion with you I have to believe
that you actually want to reach an end
like you actually I have to yeah there's
a good thing I'll argue for Solutions we
want to be heard no she wants to route
you up that's that's why she's arguing
in it so that's why you know there will
be these shame relations they'll be
moving the goal posts because she's not
trying to find the answer she's just
trying to like get a rise out of you and
that's fair enough right because you
know that's her problem is your problem
when you let that get to you and then
you start acting feminine having this
Tit for Tat and you know moving into
that lane because a you're not going to
get anywhere anyway right those
conversations never ending oh I see your
point now actually yeah yeah that makes
sense you know this last two hours of
shouting really really kind of that
never happened two she won't respect you
because you've been acting like a [ __ ]
you're arguing with her Tit for Tat you
look like one of her female friends
right now yeah no one respects that okay
I get what you're saying but you're only
talking about arguing what about I'm
talking about communication depends
conversation about it conversation where
I use a lot have gone wrong you don't
want to improve the situation by having
a conversation okay no she's not wrong
you know she's done wrong right
so she asks you you know certain
questions you're not you're not going to
respond back to it you expect her to
know what kind of conversation has
people telling you to shut up that
sounds a bit like a no I'm not talking
about I'm talking about the solution the
solution you're talking about the
problem you're talking about the
solution
okay well in a in a normal kind of
let's say a conversation we're trying to
get to a solution right
who's interested the solution in for
both parties
I don't see how if if someone's
overstepped boundaries or they've been
read or disrespectful and you now want
us to come to a solution
but you've kind of violated your end of
the agreement in terms of not being
respectful Etc then in my view I don't
really owe you yeah restarting that
conversation because that's your best so
would you ever have a conversation with
a girl about like a disagreement yeah I
State my view she states her view we can
have a a kind of a fruitful discussion
but if there's disrespect you know I
kind of just I mean it's never happened
you're saying if there's disrespect you
walk away you'll have a conversation
later if she initiates it yeah so that's
kind of that's kind of her problem you
know why I understand you know why I
understand because I mean that's bad
communication no but you know why I
understand because women are habitual
line steppers yeah and a lot of women
are habitual lines and so if they push
the line there they're like next time
and so and so when you when you do not
give them what they want right then
essentially they're going to do it again
no they'll learn because no because no
because you're doing it for a reaction
if you don't get the desired reaction
yeah they will do it you're gonna no no
you're gonna try something different so
hold on so I'm gonna try something right
here
I get it but I can play shot once I'm
going to try sharp again because if you
if I'd like to shop and you just shut up
because to me you shop even though you
feel like you've just gone quiet and
doing what you're doing that's me
and you know what I would shut up
hang on hang on I would shut up and
you'd never see me again okay and then
he's done no that's my shot because you
tried to push the boundaries twice yeah
you wanted me you tried to tell me to
shut up I'll shut up you won't see me
again
and then you're gonna be like calling
man on my phone oh my God babe come back
no you told me to shut up I'm gone no
it's I went like there's there's
boundaries you just don't cross like I
wouldn't even be that like um it
wouldn't necessarily lead to me kind of
cutting you off I would just kind of
like lose a bit of respect for you and
you'd know because because I'll kind of
look at you like
but where's the communication
communication communication tracking
isn't arguing checking is telling a
woman what it is and if she doesn't like
it then y'all move on if a woman tells
her man to shut up and he puts his head
down and says nothing it looks weak as
[ __ ] Lakers on so it seems like these
guys just like
when no it's not even necessarily
talking is communicating your point
you're about yours there's nothing wrong
with communication
hang on I'll just say this the least
amount of communication or understanding
is done during an argument
I get what you're saying
Community sorry no no go ahead yeah
communication is kind of done via when
things calmed down you know what I'm
saying that's when communication that
makes sense we need to have a you know a
respectful kind of stable conversation
but if we're at a point where she's
saying shut up man or whatever then you
know that's kind of that's funny to me
so I'd look at he's like you know and
then move on and I mean that that's just
how you hold yourself as a man if some
of you guys hear that and you think
that's weak then it's because you're
weak in it because your silence is weak
my silence is strong I don't have to
talk I don't have to you know do this
Tit for Tat thing you know we don't have
to have this conversation you know I I
do I get where you're coming from but I
kind of feel like as times are moving on
do you have to evolve as a person or as
a man
it's not it's not we shouldn't be just
stereotyped to one way of doing things
it's a course of behavior it's a course
of behavior well I'm going to be honest
with you right
I'm a 34 year old man I've been in my
fair share of relationships and I've
seen different things from different
people and like you can't always have
the same effort yes you can have your
the doctrine of keeping quiet when the
disrespect is there but there are some
people who actually don't get it so true
I've practiced I've practiced question
method practice your method sorry to
finish I've practiced your method and
sometimes that doesn't always work
question why are you dealing with
disrespect for women then because when
people don't know sometimes you don't
know the disrespect or maybe it's a case
of unto you know better you do better
right this this never happens to me this
this conversation about like please when
you write your book I will definitely
I'm writing a book actually online
is my YouTube channel but um essentially
this idea of like you know some women
are just again it's kind of framing it
like you're in a passive seat listen
you're here because I allow you to be
here right no woman can walk into my
house you can't slide into my DMs and be
present without my me deciding you can
be so this this idea that without
engaging in that yeah like this this
idea that like disrespect is some kind
of fact that the universe is no when
you're around me you're on borrowed time
you know that so don't ever speak to me
without being cautious as many of you
know you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible